Space is basically the coolest, coldest, biggest,
all-around awesomest… so many superlatives.
But what’re the brightest and darkest things
out there?
Hey, Spacefans!
Amy getting nerdiest with you today on DNews.
When we’re talking about the brightest and
darkest things in space, there are a few things
to consider, but let’s start off with what
we experience here on Earth.
We know that the brightest thing in our sky
is the Sun.
It’s a star, but it’s so close to the
Earth that it dominates the daytime sky, outshining
other stars.
After the Sun sets and we can see the other
stars, it’s easy to see that they vary in
brightness.
Astronomers have observed this for millennia
and used it as a way to catalogue stars.
More than 2,000 years ago, the Greek astronomer
Hipparchus catalogued the brightness of stars
saying that the brightest was a magnitude
1 star and the dimmest was a magnitude 6 star.
He classified stars based on their apparent
or visual magnitude.
But this isn’t a perfect method.
Not only is it measuring stars with the imperfect
human eye, it’s making measurements relative
to our Earthly perspective.
Two stars that look to be equally bright might
only appear to be so.
In reality, one could be much brighter but
further way, so it appears dimmer.
If we want to know what the brightest is,
we need to talk about absolute magnitude,
which is measuring bright things against each
other irrespective of our Earthly vantage
point.
The solution astronomers came up with was
to implement an absolute magnitude scale similar
to but more complete than Hipparchus’ scale.
A star’s absolute magnitude is determined
by calculating its brightness as it would
appear if it was 32.6 light-years (which is
a nice round 10 parsecs) from the Earth.
Astronomers can also use luminosity as a measure,
looking at the amount of light energy that
a star puts out.
So let’s look at the Sun again as an example.
Its visual magnitude, its brightness from
here on Earth, is -26.74, but its absolute
magnitude, what it would be from 32.6 light
years away, is 4.83 The brightest known star
is called R136a1.
It lies about 165,000 light years from Earth
and has a visual magnitude of 12.77.
But looking at it away from our Earthly vantage
point, 136a1 is about 10 million more luminous
than our Sun.
But even the brightest star isn’t the brightest
thing.
When stars die, they explode brilliantly in
what is called a supernova, expelling huge
amounts of energy as x-rays and gamma rays.
So how bright are supernovas?
They can shine as bright as 10 billion suns,
one was even recorded as being 600 billion
times brighter than the Sun, releasing more
energy in an instant than our Sun will over
its whole lifetime.
So they’re bright, but they don’t last
and they’re still not the brightest.
To understand the brightest sustained thing
in the Universe, we have to look at the darkest
thing in the Universe.
To consider something dark, we have to consider
how it interacts with light, because properly
speaking darkness is the absence of light.
This means we can’t really look at dark
matter as something dark because it doesn’t
interact with light at all.
But black holes do, and true to their name,
they are the darkest things in the universe.
A black holes is a highly concentrated, densely
packed gravitational point in space from which
nothing can escape.
Any material that strays too close to a black
hole will be devoured, and that generally
means stars, gases, and dust.
This cosmic material swirls around the black
hole, which is what astronomers see when they
detect a black hole, but ultimately the pull
of gravity is so strong that even light can’t
escape.
So this is what makes black holes the darkest
thing in the universe.
But the process of a black hole devouring
all that material is the opposite of dark.
Black holes rotating at the centre of galaxies
devouring material is a hugely energetic process.
Some material is sucked into the hole, but
some is sent streaming away from it in giant
jets above and below it, essentially “turning
on” what’s called a quasar.
Quasars are part of a class of objects known
as active galactic nuclei, and they release
far more energy than normal stellar production
does alone.
And that energy is bright.
Quasars can shine between 10 to 100,000 times
brighter than our own Milky Way galaxy.
So black holes are the darkest and quasars
are the brightest, but what about other superlatives
in space?
Like, who has traveled the furthest from the
Earth?
It was the crew of Apollo 13 in 1970.
And speaking of Apollo 13, how exactly did
NASA make sure there wasn’t a repeat performance
of the explosion that crippled the mission?
I talk about that this video right here.
And if you want more, I dig into loads of
of olde timey space content on my channel,
Vintage Space.